ولكن
هذا اصبح خلفنا الان التداعيات تداعيات
هذه الحرب العالم كله يعاني منها المشهد
الحالي بعد مرور اكثر من عام على الحرب
يشير الى ان كتله جديده بدات بالظهور في
مواجهه الولايات المتحده عندك روسيا
والصين من ناحيه ومن الناحيه الاخرى
الولايات المتحده ولاننا نتحدث عن اوروبا
الا ترى في هذا تراجع استراتيجي لموقع
الاتحاد الاوروبي
لا اظن ذلك
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولاله المتحده لطالما
وقفوا جنب الاجنب في المساءله التي
الاهميه خاصه فيما يخص السلام وهذا ما
يفعلونه الان ولا اي تراجعا لدوري الاتحاد
الاوروبي فهم يلعبون دورا اساسيا خاصه
فيما خصوص تقديم الدعم الاقتصادي
والولايات المتحده تلعب دور القيادي في
تزويد اوكرانيا بالدعم العسكري ولكن كل
هذا يتزامن مع
توزيعي الادوار بين اوروبا وامريكا على
مدى السنوات الطويله الماضيا وانا في
الحقيقه راضي جدا في ما يخص الدوره
الاوروبي
وفي ملفات كثيره بدات تعقد الوضع في
اوروبا لا ادري ان كانت اوروبا ستصمد ام
لا يعني اضافه للحرب في اوكرانيا هناك
ايضا ملف بدا يعود من جديد للساحه
الاوروبيه يتعلق بالبلقان وانت كنت سفير
هناك كيف ترى الوضع في البلقان هل هو مرشح
للتدهور اكثر خاصه في البوسنه
يبدو ان هنالك انجاز ايجابي تحقق هناك
الصرب وكوسفورم لا تعترفان بعضهما البعض
ولكنهم يستمرون بمحاوله
رفع الشرعيه عن الطرف الاخر ومنذ الاقتراح
الالماني
[موسيقى]
القائمه على سياسه
الجمهوريه الاتحاديه الالمانيه كما حصل
الماء الغربي لم تعترف بالمانيا الشرقيه
او لكنهم لم يمنعوا الاشخاص من التعامل
معهم وهم انفسهم ايضا
خلقوا قناه دبلوماسيه
العلاقات الالمانيه الداخليه
تقدما كبيرا على مدى السنوات في تطبيع
الاوضاع هناك من دون الاعتراف بشرعيه
الطرف الاخر
ولذلك يبدو
ان قصبه
والصرب يعملون على شيء من هذا القبيل
المسيح خطوه كبيره الى الامانه خاصه بعد
انضمام مثلا كوسوفو للامم المتحده
كما اعتقد بان سلوكيات الروسيه وحقيقه ان
روسيا يبدو انها تخسر المعركه سيضعف
موقفها في دول البلقان منطقه البلقان هل
تعتقد بانه اتفاق دايتون متعلق بالبوسنه
مازال صالح البعض يرى بانه على ابواب
الانهيار
[موسيقى]
نعم هذا ما يقولونه منذ
ان تم توقيع عليه قبل 25 عاما
ولكنني لا اعتقد بانها على وشك الانهيار
كما اعتقد بان الاوروبيين
سوف
يضغطون بشكل خاص
[موسيقى]
على مثلا
الانضمامي الصربي الى اتحاد الاوروبي
لضمان عدم انهيار الاتفاق